Hello and welcome to this video on command line. So for this we're going to be jumping into the
project and we're going to be looking at the first integration method. So if you could fire
up the project now and I will jump over. So here I am in the project and we have our first
slide up here which is the 2.1.8. Now we're not going to need... okay we can jump the first
few of these slides but what I would like to do is come to this first gray slide that says
using command line. Use the command line to change lightmap size and change the material.
Now if this is working correctly you should have this sm underscore chair highlighted in the
content browser and that is in the directory slides command line. Now I'm going to be talking
through how it integrates and how you go about finding the code that you need. So therefore
alongside what we have here I will have a web page for the API. I'll be referencing that
as we go along. Right so let's talk through what we're going to do. So the first way and
the easiest way to run Python script inside the editor is actually from the command line here
where we would usually type in CVALS or command codes. Now you'll see if you do the drop down
you have a few different options. So we have the console commands and we have Python. You can
run scripts and we can run single Python statement and show its results. We're going to use
the normal Python here and you'll see that the text is now enter Python script or file name.
Now the first problem that you're going to have is if we were to run something in Python
we're not going to be able to see the output because we have nowhere to see it.
Now in order to see it we're better off looking at the output log and that's what we're going
to be using here. Now the output log you might not have our automatic if you don't just come
up to window and you'll see that we have the output log here under logs. So just tick that on
and we'll be able to see the output. Now again this is set to console commands so I'm
going to set it to Python and I'm going to clear the log so that we can see what we're doing.
Right so the first thing that I'm going to want to do is let's run a script. So for example we have
hello world which will output directly to the Python log. Now we have an equivalent which is
for the unreal. We have a few different outputs for the unreal. So you want to print the unreal
log. First thing we're going to need is we're going to need to import the unreal library.
So as you can see here I've got import unreal. Right now if I type unreal.log
I can bring up a hello world. This is the Python log. Now we actually have a couple of
other ones we can use here. So for example we have unreal.log underscore warning and that will
warning message that's going to give us something in yellow and we also have if I do up unreal
log error which is going to return us a red version. This is just useful for us if we're
going to be doing reporting within a script. So that is allowing us to run Python in the unreal
in memory library. So let's try and do some stuff with it. So what I would like to look at
the first thing that I want to do is I want to get a reference to an asset. So in this we're going
to take this chair you're going to change the light mass the light map size and we're going
to change the material size. And I picked these two because they need to be treated in
a slightly different way. So let's start off with what we need is a reference to this chair.
So we need to be able to load that into memory. So in order to do that what I'm going to do
is I'm going to make a variable I'm going to call it chair asset and I'm going to make that equal
unreal dot load assets underscore between that load asset. Now in order to load this asset
I need a reference to it and in order to get that I'm going to go into the content browser
where my chair is highlighted right hand click and I'm going to come down to copy reference
I come back in here right click and paste that's going to give me a really long string.
Now I don't need all of this all I need is up to the sm chair and I don't need this
section at the beginning I just need the path so that should be correct I'm not getting any
error messages so in that case I'm going to run unreal dot log and I'm going to type in chair
asset and there you go we can see we have an object and it's got the reference to it
and the class here of static mesh so we now have a variable chair asset which we will be able to
to use and do stuff too. Okay so one of the things I'd like to quickly look at
is the attributes so if I was to take this out and this is useful because we're going to
be looking at the API but depending on what you have loaded into your project
the website API might not be up to date so you might have to come in and you might have to use
it from within unreal itself so what I'm doing is I'm doing for at right
beaut so I'm just setting a variable in then I'm going dir chair asset and if I press
shift and enter it's going to give me a second line down here which I can edit in and I'm just
going to print at right beaut then I press enter now all this is going to do is it is going to
give us all of the different attributes or functions and stuff that we have connected to
this class so that's useful but let's have a look at it in the API so here we are in the API
documentation and again you can just search for unreal python API do make sure you've got
the correct version things do change as they update so we're not always going to have the
same one and what I'm going to do here is I am going to search for static mesh and go
and as you can see at the top here we have the unreal dot static mesh and if I load that up
this is going to be reflected and look very similar to what we have in the editor when we
search for dir now there are some interesting oddities here so what we have at the top is
we have something that is editor properties and these are all specific properties to this class
and below this once we've gone through all the editor properties we have all of the specific
functions we've got the add material the asset add sockets what I'm going to do is I'm going to
demonstrate using both of these because if you want to you change editor material
we can actually just we're going to use the see get editor property editor set editor property
so this is going to allow us to get and set these properties and you'll see what type they
are so these are like setting variables on a on an asset however these are specific functions
because something is required to be done we can't just change the variable so we're going to change
we're going to try and we're going to go through how to change both of these
so if you see I picked light resolution for our first example which is an int 32
and for the second example I am just going to set a material so let's go down to set material
material instance new material so these are the two functions that I'm going to call and I'm going
to use that chair asset which we selected so I'm back in the editor now and what I'm going to
do is so the first thing I'm going to do is I want to change the light resolution so for that
I'm going to be using the set editor property and it's quite straightforward I want to get
the chair asset then what I want to do is set underscore add it or underscore
t and I want to tell it which property I want to change so it will be the light underscore
map underscore resolution and I'm going to update it to 128 and just to confirm I'm going
to open up the chair here before we come in and if I search for the light you'll see
the light map resolution is 64 so we should see this update okay so I think I have that
correct okay no error message so that suggests we're probably okay we can also see that the asset
is no longer saved so if I jump into it and search for the light map again see light map
resolution 128 so we've changed that editor property and that's all good right now we've
changed the asset you're going to want to save that I'm not doing it using python because it's
likely you're going to need to do that with you want to do it within the file right and to
do that we are going to use a different library so if I come in and I type in unreal dot
editor asset library dot save underscore asset now all I need to provide to this
is the path of the asset that I want to save so if I go share assets and I put dot
get underscore path underscore name so what this is doing is we're using the editor asset library
and this is really useful because this has a lot of functionality which is going to allow you to
manipulate the asset an asset browser so there is an equivalent one for actors in the scene as
well but all I'm doing is handing this over and it's already saved because I did a little
bit of faffing around but it's good that we've got that now so we've changed a editor property
and so these are like variables or something that you should be able to update on and different
classes will have a lot of different editor properties you'll be able to to update so we've
given an example of how we've done that now let's use a function in order to change something
else so in this case what I'm going to do is I'm going to change the material so we have
two materials here we have a blue and a chair and we're going to change this from the yellow
over to the blue so in order to do that I am going to grab the chair asset again
and I'm going to do dot set underscore material because we've seen that this is a function off of
a static mesh class and I need to give it zero because this is the index of the material that
I want to change oh no I'm going to load the asset because I just need to provide it a material
so the first thing I need to do is the zero again because it's the first indexed then I need
to load a material ix I need to give it an asset so we're going back again to do unreal
and we're going to use the load underscore asset so this is loading the asset into memory
we'll close that down so again I need to get a reference to a asset that I want to load so
I'm jumping back into the content browser right hand clicking on the chair I'm going to copy
reference and I am going to paste that in again I need to get rid of the m underscore chair blue
at the end and get rid of this script section at the beginning so I just have the address
press enter and bang our chair is blue so we have changed over the material and again I want
to save this so we'll have a look and the asset is got a little star means it's not saved
it's also nice about python is I can push up and down to go back through previous codes
so I'm going to jump in here and I'm going to go to the save asset again
and that will save our asset okay and that's the save the asset here so it was a bit painful
that we have to type everything in that we've got here in future we're going at a lot of saved
scripts I'm going to have more complicated stuff we're working with but I want you to see how
the basics of doing some very basic functionality with the unreal library is and also the point
you've got those editor properties which you can edit using the editor property functionality
and then you've got functions that you can call on a class and provide it with functionality so
we've done an example of both of them there so this is just bringing up on screen some of
the code that I plugged in in case it's easier to copy down from here it's rather
straightforward at this point thank you for sticking with me through that the rest of
this should be relatively straightforward in comparison but from now on we're going
to be jumping into the examples and looking at the other integration methods in the system